what um
age
were people introduced to corn
oh wow
that guy scarred me at 19.
19. or 20 19 or 20 i don't remember i
don't remember how i got introduced to
it yeah honestly
it must have been page free yeah it must
have been
and then you just kind of randomly type
in stuff on google a lot of the websites
you can't get on
um
or wasn't it like looking up yeah
looking at the top shelf yeah top
i think that was probably my 10 or 11
for me yeah i think i was about 13
yeah my friend i went to my friend
specifically room i went to my friend's
house
and i think he was like
and he was like guys there was a bunch
of guys and he was like guys look i've
got this vhs time right
is that i've got this video on my mum's
my mom's video i'm not supposed to watch
it and i was like really he was like
yeah yeah and i was like we were like
what is it because we were like 13 foot
like what is it and you put it on and it
was
like being like a 13 14 year old boy and
seeing
that
it literally just blew your mind you're
like i didn't know people done this yeah
exactly
you know what i mean so i'm just like
maybe i was you said the average age is
what 11 11 yeah and i was like 13. i
don't know but i think people are
introduced to corn quite early now
especially children yeah
so for me i i had easy access to corn um
apart from the page freezer
[Laughter]
but uncle would uh
i hope uh i hope nobody no
and fall asleep
and i'd get home from yeah it would be
on and i'd get home from school and i'd
be like and i i remember finding the
tape and i'm like okay i'm gonna make
i'm gonna make a mental note of where
this tape
is going to go and i'll retrieve it when
he's asleep or whatever we're talking
calling back in the day we're five hours
long
so wait five wait hours
yeah
the coin he had what were they doing in
the video this is different i don't know
it was just different everything yeah
different things
literally so i would just sit there for
hours watching it over and over and over
again when everybody was asleep i put it
on before school i put it on did anyone
ever catch you no
no he caught me once
he
so he didn't catch me watch anyway he
caught the aftermath because i would use
um i don't know why but i would use his
t-shirt to clean up what well you use
his t-shirt yeah
it was just the first thing i found it
wasn't it armani as well
it was the first thing i found so oh no
how do you sit again no harmony no
[Laughter]
um penance yeah so he he he grilled me
if it was me and i denied it to the
grave so i hope he never sees that how
so how do you say um 10 10 or 11.
10 and you were you were you were
jerking off at 10. yeah
watching full feature limps i think i
think this has a con like a correlation
to where you are now
100 perhaps yeah i guess so
yeah
but like it's cool i can i can control
it it's not like it's not it's not like
blind but every every new year seven
group that came into the high schools
previously working in
they were
age 11 to 12. yeah i was horrified when
i first started working there
the amount of explicit yeah
not even just what was on their phones
but just what would come out of their
mouths what they would be wanting to do
with their friend their girlfriend or
what they've done with this girl what
they haven't done and i'd be like
shut up yeah shut up you haven't made
your bed you've probably got cheese
stuck around it just please stop yeah i
can imagine what corn is like in this
channel if it was if for when it was
hard for me it was that accessible i can
imagine what it's like now the internet
is
you know what's crazy it shrinks your
brain
yeah um
a 2014 study in the journal jma
psychiatry
found men who can regularly consumed
corn had smaller brain volume and fewer
connections in this strat time
a brain region tied to reward processing
compared with those who didn't view corn
however it's possible um the brain
region shrinks simply because people
become accustomed to viewing viewing
pornographic images and thus find them
less rewarding
yeah right
um she's trying to say you've got a
small brain i don't know no i don't know
the smallest in the room
um
so it says new research from the
security technology company has reported
that children under the age of 10 now
account for 22 percent of online
jesus so
so under the age of 10. yeah so how how
crazy though is it when you think about
it like tick-tock movies like there's so
much stuff that has soft cork corn yeah
that we're not protecting like kids
against because but even what we call
soft porn corn
um
today
would have been wild say
30 years ago or 50 years ago 15 years
ago even yeah yeah
and
it's it's just really how how far are we
going with this desensitization
especially for children it's just so
dangerous
so do you guys think
that
we should have because we were talking
earlier you think we should have more
knowledge for like kids around sex ed
and like that sort of thing
100
so what does that look like to you to me
especially having worked in education
for such a long time
and then meeting 11 year olds who have
absolutely no idea what sex is how it
works what a relationship is what is a
healthy and a non-healthy relationship
i believe that if more
if it was seen as less taboo in society
and more parents in the household were
discussing sex with their children from
a young age discussing childbirth where
children come from how are children made
and the biology of it and the love side
of it yeah if that was given to children
from a young age i guess the curiosity
for all this hardcore stuff
wouldn't be so
shocking yeah i i don't is there any
evidence that really suggests that
exposing kids to sex ed and corn earlier
results in promiscuity or something and
less promiscuity
because from what i've seen it's really
the opposite because after they
introduce sex out in school the opposite
result happened yeah
but that's school yeah but i do think i
do think parents should
because otherwise your kids are learning
from their peers
so and and they're gonna go i mean you
should be i feel like parents should be
just transparent so it shouldn't it
should be what you said and and the love
aspect of it but you should also
you should so
you should be in the same line of who
they're likely to be learning from
outside of the household because
whatever you say at home they're going
to rebel against and it's more likely to
be different from whatever necessarily
it depends on the way in which you teach
but yeah but it's also like as a parent
you vet who your kid hangs out with yeah
and you vet with schools they go to we
didn't have sex at my high school we
didn't have a problem with teen
pregnancies we're just but you can only
vet for so long once they get to 11 yeah
you're not really they're at high school
now so your your contact with the school
and the parents for example is no i mean
but you can home school i don't actually
know what the laws are around
homeschooling but it's pretty easy you
can homeschool or like go to a smaller
school that sort of thing i personally
think the earlier you
um
introduce it to them the earlier they're
going to be inquisitive to the physical
side of it me personally um i think
many many many many many years ago it
would have been
sex itself would have been very much a
ritual
practice
so it would have been
very sacred et cetera et cetera yeah but
because it's normalized now if you don't
see the actual physical watch you might
see a rendition of it in a music video
people are now saying oh we might as
well introduce it to them because they
see so and so shaking their bum and da
da da da and kids are doing it then we
automatically associate that movement
with sex and then
it becomes a domino effect yeah me i
wouldn't want my daughters to know about
it until they actually
having certain feelings or she begins uh
but period but you wouldn't know that's
the thing too late did you see one so so
i think it it should start with the
parents having no boundaries in terms of
open conversation and communication
because if your daughter knows there's
certain things she can't come to you or
or her mom about
it
she's gonna go she's just it's never
going to happen and
if going by what you're saying if you
don't introduce it in the beginning
if you wait until she has those feelings
when she has those feelings she's not
coming to you because you already don't
have that open communication
specifically about sex people feel
embarrassed about sex i think it depends
on the relationship that you have it
doesn't matter so so for example my
sister my little sister i was fine
no i mean so yeah i mean i don't know
what the rule on the exception is but
for example my little sister we raised
her like
to her
my brother and i are her her dad right
so we raised her as best we could right
and she had a ton of respect for us
however when she hit a peak age when
she's going out she's pulling up her
skirt it doesn't matter the relationship
we have at a certain point she's going
to make these decisions for herself so
even if not with everyone but i feel
like even if you do your best at some
point she's gonna yeah they're gonna
they're gonna find out about it that's
that's true but i i need to see evidence
that more exposure to those sorts of
things reduces promiscuity yeah because
i i'm i'm telling you so we'll wrote a
whole book on this yeah and it has the
opposite effect right so when they
introduced sex ed in schools and in more
of the culture promiscuity went up
i'm not down for everyone here do you
think that you would have benefited more
from being taught about sex by your
parents or by your school i think
personally me for like a hundred percent
because like i said
actually to be fair i was the first one
out of my friends to lose their vision
but of course you were but yeah
it wasn't my choice
for example had your uncle for example
sat you down yeah once he realized that
you had found his collection
and had an open honest conversation with
you around the safety around the
expectations around the differences in
this and real life relationships etc etc
and then spoke to you about his culture
of his use of it do you not think that
that would have been
foundation laying
for you to not then go
oh so exciting it's so exciting yeah
yeah so i agree yeah so yeah so if it
would alter the course of my
my development in that in that area
because it would have been not
normalized but like if if it's a person
i look up to
and
i aspire to be like i'm more likely to
listen to them so even if it won't be
the parent you know
whatever you're talking about nonsense
i'm going to go listen to my friends
because i want to be like you everything
even if i can relate to your youth if
you bring me down and you tell me when i
was this age i did this to normalize it
even more but whereas as opposed to
taboo and off limits and things like
that if he was to sit you down and have
that conversation about the birds and
the bees and relationships
your only recollection of
sex up to that point is porn so
regardless you're going to go that corn
you're going to go that way
because as you said you look up to him
so you're going to imitate what he does
and you're like if you can do it i can
do it that's when you're and it wasn't a
little bit irresponsible though for him
to like yeah very 100 yeah so i'm
leaving that around my thing is i think
most adults are ill-equipped to have
this conversation do you think so i
think
you're right it takes a
someone that isn't
i don't want to say isn't watching corn
but understands that the the
problems they've come up with
yeah exactly the repercussions
to have a
mindset to say this is how i can talk to
this child because what you'll find is
if an adult
has a conversation with a child
which is trying to reassure them they
may just be exposing them to
things that they never really needed to
know yeah and it can be really
detrimental to the child
mindset and the thing is once like you
take away a kid's innocence they can't
get that back
and so my mom always tried to keep me as
innocent as possible for as long as she
could and i just i was always really
grateful for that because i had some
friends where like their innocence was
like lost a lot younger and they were
like sleeping around in like i don't
know 14 15 years old and i just grew up
in a family where that was protected and
valued so i don't know why
that's like one of the most valuable
things you have as a kid
do you equate innocence with lack of
knowledge yes yeah of course like if
you're more innocent if you're bothered
but i mean
but also we're trying to find that fine
line because we live in a society that
is quite perverted and there are
children that get taken advantage of
it's that um fine line of trying to find
where you what you're what you should be
telling your children to protect them
right versus
what you should be telling them to just
i don't know
exactly i think that's what i think this
easiest way to do it then is instead of
it being right and wrong yeah
is how you deem corn
healthy for your child or unhealthy
you're asking me just in general like
that all right like for me i've been on
both sides so i've watched corn i've
done those things i now don't do them
because i yeah deem it to be unhealthy i
don't deem it to be beneficial to me
mm-hmm but you can't control the
consumption of it outside of the
household of course
there's always going to be external
factors in everything
but would you deem it to be healthy to
introduce them to that and say this is
that so so i wouldn't
i'm not i wouldn't say i'm an advocate
for introducing it to them ahead of time
because just so they don't find that
outside of the house but i think
i think the most important factor in
affecting how they consume corn or how
they view sex is
your relationship with your child from
the very beginning just in general do
you know what i mean because
because
in my upbringing my aunties one of my
aunties raised my brother and i and it
was like a typical parent children oh we
teach you how to put a condom on a
banana or whatever it is let's laugh
about it because it's embarrassing
however
when they were away we were fingering
our
our
family
friend like not cousins but let's just
call them cousins family friends yeah
family friends you know i mean
cousins in the same in the same
environment where they've already showed
us how to put a condom on a banana but
that's because we didn't have a
relationship
and it wasn't
whatever you tell me now is you're cool
but eventually i'm going to give in to
my urges and i'm if when she comes
around i'm going to finger her so
actually you're going to have those
urges regardless of whether they taught
you but that's what that's what i'm
saying but if i had a better
relationship from the beginning not not
a parent and a child relationship just
obviously there's got to be some some
element of that but if i had a better
relationship with with my aunties or my
uncles or my mom or dad
i'm going to have the urges but it won't
be taboo
to go on chances it won't be it won't be
a dirty thing that i'm waiting to do
after they they're backstage and it will
be normal and it's like okay well you
wanna do you wanna do it in front of
them like i like i mean yet
like i just i'm trying to no answer
watch this
look what i learned there's no parent in
their right mind is going to be like yes
bring the hose over i mean
i think it comes back to what would
rather you
do it
at their house
instead of out in the streets because
i've heard parents
say that they'll
underage drinking they'll be like oh i'd
rather have them do it here than
somewhere else
and so parents would rather have their
degree i mean i think drinking but it's
another thing when you can make a child
from it no but that's not it's not that
i want to do it in front of them but i
just remember how
filthy we were
despite them just doing the regular
parent thing and being like this is poor
this is what it is i
have i remember we were like
it was nasty
but it was nasty because it was off
limits
that's the only reason it's nasty that's
do you know what i mean like it's it's
interesting because our experience is
like i had a really similar like it was
off limits but i just didn't do it and
i'm like grateful for that yeah
do you think the more it becomes taboo
the more people want to do it yes i
think naturally yeah just human nature i
guess not me
a special breed but i think she's an
anomaly i don't know i'm just telling
you by high school we didn't like it
wasn't that it was a wild like that
really yeah and we had we had chastity
speakers every year oh my gosh
we had no we had no teen pregnancies at
my high school except possibly one but
this girl was crazy i feel like she was
lying for her to like
i never saw a baby
she was like i'm pregnant but there's no
baby yeah like i'm not gonna speak for
her lexi i hope you're good
i think it comes back to what ish was
saying with regards to
parents being ill-equipped
if a parent is equipped and has
knowledge has a research and there was
more of a
societal norm
that
you did speak to your children about
childbirth and relationships and loving
your partner and
that kind of stuff then and it as it as
the age increases and it becomes more
age-appropriate to then
talk about sex and lovemaking
in that manner
then i don't think it would bring on
more promiscuity can you say you're
equipped to have the conversation i
believe i am if you
watch a lot of corn and if you can't
maintain a
a healthier health and this is why i
think you can
because you're not speaking from
experience on the other side so what you
know is corn and isn't that like the
blind leading the blind right no but if
it's not my idea right if i'm if i'm a
drug addict yeah i know i don't want my
child to be a drug addict if i'm obese i
know how i've gotten here and if i can
stop this person from doing that i'm
yeah but i i'm in an ideal position to
be like don't but i wouldn't want an
obese trainer
but you need to be healed
you need to you need to be healed that's
what that's that's
sorry if i set you the task of oh go x
amount of time without it mm-hmm just to
see the flip side then you can speak
from both sides
i've done it then you know if it's
healthy or unhealthy yeah
ultimately
i've gone on the flip side and gone
without how long has it i don't know
months three